welcome to New San Francisco I want to
hire you pick up a package bring it back
I can make your every wish come true so
John what do you wish for toilet paper
three Plies this roll was made for you
to get things started though I'm just
gonna ask in the honor of Sweet Tooth
and his truck what is the best ice cream
flavor well I have to say I'm a
strawberry guy
um now when I was in college I used to
eat so much and this is not a plug I
used to eat so much Haagen-Dazs that I
had a 50 off family member's card to the
Haagen-Dazs on 72nd and Broadway that's
impressive yeah my dude if maduja here
is still working that shout out to you
here
series I
I was wondering the scenes that you shot
opposite Sweet Tooth and obviously Samoa
Joe is the body and he did such a great
job acting out the voice but it's well
on its voice so what are you acting
opposite is somebody saying the lines or
how are you how are you filming those
scenes together no no no no no Samoa Joe
learned all the lines and we were acting
off each other will came in afterwards
and like picked up his energy and his
Vibe and put those lines in there but
Samoa Joe gave an amazing performance
dude like it's it was it was really
impressive how he took on his character
and created this character dude let's
take that a step further this The Thong
Song the casino scene is so brilliant
because number one I heard that he said
he you said he really wanted to Pummel
you because you're an Avenger that maybe
you went a little harder on you how
badly did he Pummel you and then talk
about singing the song The Thong Song
because I think you could re-release it
in 2023 now
what what all night long let me see
no he definitely gave me a uh a
conventional ass whooping as they would
call it uh I know one thing I could
never be a wrestler because that dude
don't know his own strength so I know he
hurts people but it was fun you know
I've been a fan of Cisco and Drew Hill
you know since I I am a member of
unleash the dragon fan club so you know
it's um it was amazing we were able to
pick that song and get it clear to use
yeah so if there
forward
bring in for like a scene a cameo who
would that singer be MC Hammer without
question already know it and I would
want him to do the Chinese typewriter
across the casino
and you'd be doing it of course I'd be
doing it with him of course MC Hammer
you know you can't I mean every time a
zombie try to get him he go Can't Touch
This banana you can't beat that are you
gonna wear the pants too of course I am
I still have my MC Hammer doll
no in the original packaging yes I was I
I was a big MC Hammer fan so if I had
the opportunity I would bring him to him
okay so I have to ask about the stunt
driving all that you did you're one of
the only actors in history
congratulations to drive a car through a
mall was it the training because I heard
you got a car and then you did it
yourself you did a lot of training but
talk about like driving through a mall
how cool was that and just sort of like
how intense like how good a Stunt Driver
are you at this point it was a lot of
fun it was a lot of fun I mean we had
four cars because we bumped and bruised
them and some of them didn't work and
some of them were just parts and but I
had a great Stunt Driver
um who did all the drifting and to
jumping and all that stuff and all the
craziness but I did get the you know
haul ass through a mall uh for a full
day and swing around a few corners and
grab some Jordans and all that stuff how
satisfying that must have been okay it
was a lot of fun but real quick you
posted a picture with Harrison Ford on
the set of Captain America and and you
said he taught you how to whoop ass or
he when he shows you how to whip ass you
listen so what was that experience
working with him because he intimidates
the heck out of me every time I talk to
him and what can fans expect the tone of
the movie to be uh Harrison was cool we
had a lot of fun and uh he really just
took on the whole Marvel family and crew
and made it uh his own you know he would
be on set and he'd be like okay let's
shoot this and everybody ah you know so
that was his thing you know when he had
us all his information he would yell out
let's shoot this piece of so that's
when we knew we were ready but um the
tone of the movie is you know it's it it
Harkens back to the original Captain
America series with that grounded
reality that the Avengers and Captain
America started in and uh growing from
there well congratulations on this I
think role is
you feel that way I would agree there's
a lot of me in this role I was allowed
to have fun but finally
that's rude not to introduce yourself
before pulling a gun on someone
first of all I've been asking everybody
in the cast because of Sweet Tooth in
honor of Sweet Tooth and his ice cream
truck what is the best flavor of ice
cream in your opinion oh butter pecan
that was quick you were very decisive
people had a hard time deciding you know
what you look like I would specifically
I'm from the south specifically Bluebell
butter pecan ice cream is okay you just
made me want that I don't even know what
that is but I want it immediately
um this character quiet is so amazing
it's such a great series by the way and
such great character development I'm
wondering how you crafted this character
because she is like a stream of
Consciousness like her name is quiet but
when she talks it's like
you know so how did you craft her I mean
I I didn't I I didn't it was our writing
staff that crafted her you know I mean I
truly my job really is just to pull what
they've made off the page and like give
it life
um but the road map was all there I
think the maybe the thing that I added
was you know I I bring a lot of my own
like
stupid goofy humor and that is certainly
something that I wanted to like do more
and more of as we shot the series it was
so fun to you know try to make Anthony
laugh or break you know it was so fun to
try dumb stuff physical comedy you know
weird just like completely unhinged
comedy that would make um Michael
Jonathan Smith our showrunner laugh like
that was always like ah yes I've made
him laugh but yeah I I think like when I
think about
crafting a character or like thinking
about an arc yeah
um I really stick to like what is on the
page so like he shot this out of order
so what I did was I like nerdly had you
know like posts Post-its and cards and I
would like write okay this scene and
this act and this is what we're doing
and this and it's in this episode and I
had them like plastered all over the
walls of the basement of the house that
I was staying in so that I could lock in
on like where am I in the story what is
happening for her right now where has
she been where is she going and where am
I today before lunch
as we go into that scene you and Anthony
together you talked a little bit about
it and he's talked about how he's like a
five-year-old inside and that he really
because he's so funny in Marvel but he
really got to unleash that side of
himself I'm wondering how the two of you
work together was there obviously the
writing was incredible very sort of
Deadpool in its style I would say but
it's it's its own thing but I'm
wondering how you two work together
because it really felt like when I was
watching you that's the kind of stuff I
would think but never say so I'm
wondering how you played off of each
other were you just letting it like
spitballing was there a ton of takes or
was it very precise with with what was
on the script a little both I mean we
definitely stuck to what was on this
trip but then we also let loose and had
fun I think they're you know it I'll
I'll tell you what when it's when the
world has ended like why holds your
tongue anymore you know and I think that
that was a Guiding Light for me with
that character I was like at a certain
point she just can't she can't keep it
inside anymore and everything she's been
wanting to say for a really long time is
just coming out I had a lot of fun
working with Anthony in those scenes
like we really enjoy playing off of each
other I think he's such a talented actor
I've said this over and over but I think
he's just really talented and he's very
very driven and he's really precise and
he's smart and for me as somebody is
coming into action stuff for the like
really for one of the first times I mean
I did a little on Brooklyn Nine-Nine but
nothing like this to be able to witness
someone who's done so much of it in his
career and like how he executes and what
he listens to and what he's doing and
how he's managing you know these pretty
high pressure situations
um and just executing for the camera
like incredibly incredibly deftly and
quickly and it was like it was truly
like really awesome to see him
not awesome in the small sense like
awesome but it was like awesome to see
him work like that and to be able to
like take it and take notes clearly
really played really well off of each
other speaking of Brooklyn Nine-Nine I
think of the line what kind of woman
doesn't have an ax and I think her and
quiet have a little bit of a kinship
what do you think
they have a kinship
um yeah I may or may not be coming out
with a little a little um some merch
merch based around some axes you know I
think I have to send you a little
sweatshirt or something I love that you
were the Grand Marshal at the Indy 500
and you got to do a laugh I wonder how
that compared to doing stunts in this
and who's the better ride-along because
you rode along with Mackie and rode
along with somebody at the 8500 who's
the better ride-along but mackie's an
incredible ride-along he's hilarious
he's got great tasted music he's an
amazing driver but driving wise he's not
quite as good as the drivers of ND I
tell you what the second lap after after
we took that second lab I was so sad
because I thought oh no it's over all I
want to do is do like another 500 laps I
have been bit by the racing book I I I'm
just like I can't I can't go fast enough
it's awesome hi everybody
go I'm asking everybody in the cast what
is the best ice cream and you get final
word because you are sweet tooth and you
drive an ice cream truck in this uh the
best ice cream is the chocolate
multi-crunch from Rite Aid
actually out there in Southern
California so I mean if you all need to
know yes you do need to try it it is
you're missing out on life it's not
found in a boutique ice cream booth that
is not found uh anywhere in the world it
is found at your local Rite Aid
chocolate Malta crunch go get you cone
thank me later I don't like the high-end
ones personally so I have to say
congratulations on this role this is an
incredible performance it's your first I
think screen performance I don't know
what it is about wrestlers they just
make great actors and they have such a
great physicality so I'm wondering for
you in crafting this character of Sweet
Tooth and the physicality and you kind
of have to over exaggerate because you
are wearing a mask how did you go about
crafting this character because it is an
inspired performance and a brilliant
character I appreciate that and I think
it goes back to kind of what you alluded
to earlier is that you know in the
progressing ring uh it's very important
to be able to communicate I think it's
probably one of the the
most important things that we could
possibly do in that ring so uh for me
you know it was very much you know
working it working Beyond The Mask you
know being able to emote Beyond uh you
know having essentially a stone smiling
face on you at all times and um you know
it's it's just something that you know
we as as wrestlers work on it's part of
our craft and uh to be able to translate
that to a performance uh on the
streaming screen
um you know it it it's a lot easier for
us than I think most
I didn't even realize that you did
verbalize all your stuff even though
Will Arnett ended up being the voice of
the character and I asked him in
particular about the scene where you
meet each other in the casino and you
break into the Thong Song so I want to
know number one how was your rendition
of the Thong Song
magical but continue
go on no go on and then I'll ask you
part two oh well my my rendition of the
Thong Song was was was damn near Pitch
Perfect uh at certain times you know
Anthony started to dance because he's
feeling it you know because you know I
get I get that deal yeah yeah I mean I
do the whole nine you know it was it was
really you gotta feel it you know if
you're gonna do Cisco you can only do
them 100 you can't do Cisco 80 it's
ridiculous
he was freaking hair like hilarious
that's why I love this because it's
creators of Deadpool and the boys and
just it has that menacing this character
but the funny with it
um and then the second part was Anthony
did say that he thinks you went extra
hard on him and didn't pull any punches
because he's an Avenger and he's like I
think he wanted to you know give the
Avenger a rough time is that true
absolutely correct Captain America can
get it you know I mean he's Captain
America right you know he got a standard
he got a toughness standard I'm just I'm
ensuring the toughest standard stays in
place
so you know we had to get Anthony up in
the air a few times that just that's
just something had to happen and I'm
happy to report Captain America every
bit as tough as you think he is there we
go boom thanks to him
being spun around by you it was
absolutely hilarious it's my
understanding that as soon as they said
Twisted Metal you were like I'm in so
were you what was your experience with
the game and did you play it again in in
crafting this performance and did you
draw anything from the game I mean I've
played every version of twist and know
that that's ever been put out and uh you
know like I said I think if you own a
PlayStation as a kid Twisted Metal was
only one of the few games that came out
that you were playing because you know
the rest of them were okay but then
Twisted Metal that was something
different or something that you know all
your friends came over you played on the
couch had yourself a nice little wheel
death match and a great time so for me
uh yeah Twisted Metal was definitely a
big part of my history and then uh my
friends knowing how much I love that
when they offered me a sweet tooth uh it
was it was in the definite yes so I need
to ask you so the other famous clown I
think of and I think you could go Toe to
Toe Pennywise absolutely so tell me if
this was a Pay-Per-View event and it's
sweet tooth versus Pennywise like why is
why why are you kicking pennywise's butt
oh it's quite simple because Pennywise
he considers of manifestation of evil
that he goes around and sewers and he
hunts small children well Pennywise when
you're gonna find out when Sweet Tooth
comes to town that when I get down the
sewer not everything floats especially
I'm done hacking on it so please feel
more than welcome to come out and Chase
these kids because if you want to come
get some ice cream I got all you need
that was amazing that was amazing what
was your favorite 90s reference in this
because I don't know if you remember the
turnovers with the icing that you
squeeze on and you decorate it that
turns up in one of the episodes the
Kool-Aid line like the lines The
Nostalgia who's your favorite no I'm not
sure if this made it into the Final Cut
but there was one scene where there was
a Face-Off radio where you know I don't
know if kids don't know about this back
in the day but keep your radio from
getting stolen sometimes you take the
face off put it in your pocket walk into
the mall with it and we did have a
Face-Off radio on one of the cars and if
that got any love that pop beat because
I mean that that make me laugh because
you know I mean everybody had that
Kenwood back in the day with the the
face that you took off
I have no idea
people trying to bring
them This Is Our Land he's a Royal Road
you're sitting in your virtual right in
front of an ice cream truck so I have to
ask you I know agent stone is not a fan
of the man who drives the truck but
settle the score what is the best ice
cream that's funny
um um that's hilarious
um the best ice cream I see I don't know
what he's packing on board oh your
personal favorite ice cream oh me
personally uh I don't know I'm not I
don't really eat much ice cream
something like I don't know like a
caramel crunch or some something
involving caramel and you know and ice
cream but uh no I thought you meant
specifically what he has what he has on
board and he let me know he already let
me know what he had on board so I wanted
to ask you agent stone is from Twisted
Metal black the game okay where are you
playing the game back in the 90s early
2000s oh God no you did not you were not
a gamer I'm way too old to have been a
gamer even in the 90s
um no I mean I had a vague awareness of
it uh because I have teenage daughters
and my older daughter who's a college
sophomore she had friends like when she
was growing up who were like oh God they
love that game name you know but my
daughters were not PlayStation people
they were Xbox and switch and whatever
other platforms they were on they they
weren't PlayStation
so did you visit the games at all in
creating this character because I'm
going to say upon what drives agent
Stone no the most research I did
uh was really just going online and
looking at the various iterations of
stone in the different versions of the
game but that was really just kind of a
like a visual reference uh the only
thing that I use were the scripts it's
an amazing series like oh thank you it's
yeah no it really is I mean you have
that balance of the producers of
Deadpool creator of the boys it balances
it really captured the joy and Chaos of
the game and it's really its own thing
it feels very very unique
I mean these are three winners that's
the trifecta right
um You are a man of the 90s Wings was in
the 90s tell me what your favorite 90s
reference was from this particular
series that you shot oh some of the
music some of the music
um you know like you know if I I loved
Faith No More it was one of my favorite
bands in the 90s the fact that they you
know got a music cue from Faith No More
but even I'm a hard rock guy
and and I know like at one point they
were going to try and get a Limp Biscuit
song which I would have loved but then
we ended up I think we ended up getting
a slipknot cue and actually kind of know
Corey Taylor the lead singer a little
bit so I was really excited that we got
a Slipknot song I think we did I'm
pretty sure we did the music's
incredible I'm a I'm a metal I'm a hard
rock girl I'm not like a metal girl but
a heart like AC DC Twisted Sister I
guess is 80s but like yeah leopard
because I'm older
um but I but it continued in the 2000s
and you know and there's there's a lot
of there's a lot of hard rock now that I
really really like
so I'm uh I'm kind of a metal guy I'm
more of a metal guy in terms of the
driving stuff did you get your stunts on
like were you were you did some of them
yeah we did we did some of them I mean
we had to you know we we definitely we
had to do some of the you know the
Practical stuff of chasing uh John Doe
and quiet and maneuvering in that
abandoned Six Flags where we shot all
that you know amusement park
post-apocalyptic stuff which is crazy
because I've actually shot there before
yeah and I did another picture called um
uh Killer Joe with Matthew McConaughey
we shot there two Texas boys he must
have had fun yeah we did a lot of fun
well this is great this was amazing just
to wrap things up your favorite
one-liner that you got to say because
there's so many juicy great lines
okay man I don't remember I don't know
or a scene yeah I mean I've seen that I
really like is is when the guy's shining
my shoes
and you kind of see the malevolence of
stone and that scene where the guy
misses a spot and you just kind of see
that that mer his homicidal side just
kind of and it's the guy's just shining
my shoes yeah but but you see this flash
they might it flashes through my eyes
like I might need to kill you for
blowing the the shoe shine job you know
I think that was a fun scene